[Musique]
stéphane a profité de ce nouveau bateau
tout l'été
tom venu il la porte chez son
concessionnaire pour une réparation
le lendemain catastrophe on lui annonce
que son bateau de plus de 75000 dollars
a été volé stéphane et chavirer mais il
se dit qu'un assureur du concessionnaire
va l'indemniser erreur le
concessionnaire lui apprend qu'il n'est
pas assuré contre le vol
c'est surprenant mais les garages et les
concessionnaires n'ont pas l'obligation
de souscrire à une assurance pour
couvrir les dommages ou le vol d'un
bateau laissé par un client en passant
même chose pour les concessionnaires et
les garages automobiles
mais stéphane n'en revient pas il devra
faire une réclamation auprès son propre
assureur payer la franchise est
probablement revoir ses primes augmenter
le fin mot de l'histoire
pour ne pas vous retrouver dans le même
bateau que stéphane vérifier que le
commerçant est bien assurée